here's everyone Deadpool kills in the
Marvel Universe part one so Deadpool
kills the Marvel universe is a story
where he's committed to an insane asylum
by the X-Men in order to cure him of his
inner voices the problem is that the
head of the insane asylum a guy named
psycho man wakes up Deadpool to the fact
that he's a come of a character and
nothing he does matters so the first
person the Deadpool kills is psychoman
by basically using his head as a stamp
on Deadpool's own release form after
that Deadpool kills all the hospital
orderlies and then he blows up the
entire Hospital killing all the
remaining patients after that he goes to
visit the Fantastic Four we don't see
how he kills Reed Richards but he
disintegrates Ben Grimm the thing and
then he crashes the ship into Johnny
Storm and cuts Johnny Storm's head off
blood splashes all over Susan's storm
who uses her powers to blow up
Deadpool's head but Deadpool's head
comes back because of his healing factor
and he kills Susan storm and then he
tases The Watcher to death then he cuts
his head off make sure you fall off a
part two